salut à tous et le mois de juillet est
donc pour nous comme tous les mois de
juillet depuis huit ans maintenant c'est
les vacances et les vacances va ça
signifie pas de vidéo 9 du coup ce que
vous allez regarder dans quelques
secondes c'est un des bonus dvd qui
était donc sur un dvd joueur du grenier
donc pour ça que l'épisode sera un peu
plus court que d'habitude donc ne vous
inquiétez pas en attendant on se
retrouve pour nouveau vrai jdg au mois
de septembre ce qu'on va recommencer la
bientôt début août a recommencé à bosser
du coup mais le temps de produire la
vidéo ça nous amène à début septembre
pour le prochain jbg salut à tous et
bonne vidéo
[Musique]
salut à tous ce avec accès la mise en
scène d'intro la plus courte qu'on ait
jamais faite n'arrivant même temps ses
dvd ouais c'est vrai ab ça veut dire que
je peux garder mon costume de dinosaures
ah oui tu peux très jolie d'ailleurs
merci salut à tous avec acti vision n'a
pas fait que d'excellents jeux comme
call of duty
cette phrase était très bizarre ils ont
aussi fait d' horribles purger justement
c'est un de leurs plus beaux kaka qu'on
va aller renifler aujourd'hui est
vieille hostage rescue sorti en 2004 sur
pc un des nombreux fps fini à la pisse
dans seul le pc a le secret le jeu
commence par une prise d'otage dans une
supérette bon ben écoutez il faut bien
commencé en bas de l'échelle il faudra
sauver les trois otages retenus à
l'intérieur et nous on est deux voilà il
ya moi et puis il ya le policier qui m'a
emmené en voiture je suppose
voilà voilà [ __ ] il a l'air
complètement débridée
et donc le but du jeu en même temps
c'est marqué dans le titre est de
ramener les otages ici voyez dans le
petit carré rouge
bref on prend notre matériel
d'infiltration c'est à dire un gros
fusil à pompe et c'est parti à temps
c'est pas typiquement le genre de
situation où tu envoies un négociateur
je veux dire c'est pas des terroristes
quoi c'est juste trop pauvre type qui
voulait voler la caisse et ça a mal
tourné c'est pas un peu exagéré n'en
voyez quelqu'un pour les buts et
monsieur le président on encore une
prise aux avantages chez mamadou 8e en
fait décoller les ficelles évidemment
comme dans tout bon jeu vous pouvez
choisir votre approche vous pouvez
crocheter directement les portes pour y
aller furtivement ou défoncées les
serrures que tu dis à pompe si vous
voulez aller plus vite mais bon
visiblement ça va alors dit se pose pas
de question je vous préviens et
j'entends le moindre flic approcher tous
les otages
enfin de quoi après est-ce qu'on a parlé
évidemment des graphismes on retrouve
toute l'ambiance chaleureuse d'une
supérette américains aiment regarder
cette opulence et ses rayons qui
dégueule de nourriture un
[ __ ] de crise merci obama bon cela dit
c'est bien foutu à le gérant du magasin
il a bien pris la peine de mettre un
petit peu nos magasins pour pas se
perdre quand il est dans son arrière
boutique avant tu me diras vu que la
supérette a fait quatre [ __ ] inde étage
alors que yakou le rez-de-chaussée qui
sert les panneaux c'est peut-être normal
quant à l'animation des otages mais elle
est juste effroyable mais [ __ ] mais
regardez les vu la lumière du sauveur
jésus-christ
sérieuses se sont même pas fait chier à
modéliser deux têtes différentes dans
tout le jeu est la seule tête qu'ils ont
fait on dirait une photo volée
et niveau intelligence artificielle
c'est évidemment de la viande de premier
choix les otages se coince dans les
ports tu arrêtes de te suivre sans
aucune [ __ ] de raison ou se coince
dans
rien mais tu fais quoi là tu est coincé
par quoi les molécules d'oxygène mais
[ __ ] minimum d'autonomie s'il vous
plaît je viens de libérer les otages
tués tous le preneur d'otages et ya
genre 12 mètres à faire en ligne droite
alors débrouille-toi bordel de merde que
tu es un [ __ ] de flics pas une femme
enceinte évidemment on n'a pas parlé du
jeu en lui même mais niveau gameplay
c'est une catastrophe je veux dire 70%
du gameplay dans ce niveau 1 consiste à
ouvrir des portes et même sa ouvrir une
simple [ __ ] de porte c'est raté quand
tu ouvre une porte tu te pousse toi même
on m'a jamais pris ça au vieil
réalité pour passer les portes il faut
appuyer sur eux et reculé puis ré a
avancé pour passer à travers la porte
faut surtout pas essayer de passer à
travers les ouvertures de la porte sinon
tu te bloque systématiquement mais
bordel
[ __ ] je peux plus passer la porte j'ai
ouvert la porte comme un gros bad ass en
tirant dessus et maintenant je suis
bloqué comme un débile et [ __ ] mais
arrêter de fermer les portes derrière
vous laisser ouvertes toutes façons vous
n'arrivez pas à les passer sinon sérieux
mais c'est une super et tout ça
d'instituts spécialisés pour les débiles
mentaux le jeu s'appelle fbi haye
hostage rescue et la partie sauver les
otages du jeu est complètement buggé
bord une fois que vous avez ramené tous
les gros débile dans le carré rouge
avoue passés au niveau 2 et cette fois
le jeu va vous demander d'aller libérer
des otages dans un bus [ __ ] sérieux
mais pourquoi on y va tout seul il y a
dix terroristes ils retiennent deux
personnes en otage ils ont un
lance-roquettes et 8h30 regardent ils
peuvent pas rajouter quelques flics là
contrôlé par l'ordi juste pour
l'ambiance même si ça aura rien je veux
dire activision-blizzard même fait dans
le premier colloque qui pourtant étaient
sortis l'année d'avant favorable donc
c'est de la merde hein les ennemis sont
des fois tantôt complètement aveugle eux
tantôt il te tire dessus à travers la
texture tantôt ils sont complètement
immortel
c'est quoi ce délire j'ai une arme à
blanc je t'aime et quelle merde ce truc
mais [ __ ] ça me casse les couilles j'y
viens l'arrachent
alors on n'a clairement pas s'amuser à
faire tous les niveaux il faut pas
déconner c'est un bonus dvd sarcasme les
niveaux se ressemblent tous sont
insupportables à jouer d'autant que les
bugs de collision et de gestion des
otages rendre le jeu dur mais pas pour
une bonne raison ce jeu me rappelle un
peu le jeu de la ville est que ces
entités aura force mais bon est-ce que
c'est pire je sais pas je veux dire
d'entités rose que même il y avait
chirac en 3d et puis chirac quand tu lis
dizaines de fibres mais lui au moins il
écoute et
je m'appelle le clairac
[Musique]